-Our next guest is a very
funny actress, comedian,
and best-selling author
you know from her work
in movies like "Obvious Child"
and shows such as
"Parks and Recreation"
and "The Great North."
She co-created, co-wrote,
voiced, and produced
"Marcel the Shell
With Shoes On,"
which is in select theaters
this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-Rolling. Give me some levels.
-Give -- give you some levels?
Like --?
-Just, like, talk.
-Like --
Oh, uh -- Hello.
My name is Marc-- Mar...
[ Sighs ]
It's not the first time
I've done that.
My name is Marcel,
and I'm partially shell,
as you can see on my body.
But I also have shoes and...
a face.
-Please welcome back to the
show, our very good friend,
Jenny Slate, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Jenny, you look wonderful.
-What the heck?
-I should have kept my
suit on.
-I know it. I know.
Or it's just weird that you
also didn't have a --
-Oh, you should
have brought me one.
-Yeah, John stole my bit,
so I just left it, you know?
-You look very --
you look so beautiful.
So put together.
But you had quite an ordeal
getting here today.
-Here's what happened.
And this is a real, fresh story.
It's really real.
-This is the today story.
-This is -- Yeah, this is
really what happened.
So, like most people who
go on an airplane,
I fell asleep on the way to
the airport.
Got on the plane, and
immediately was like --
[ Snoring ]
Like, just down, just out.
And then, like, woke up
just long enough to
recline a tiny bit more and just
get deeper into that slumber.
And then woke up when
the plane was like --
[ Imitates metal creaking ]
You know?
And then woke up, ripped open
a thing of, like, cashews
and was like glug, glug, glug.
Just a class act.
Class act all the way through.
And waltzed off the plane,
and when I got out
of the airport,
I realized that I had left
this dress on the airplane.
-Oh, like,
a carry-on garment bag?
-Yeah, because I was like --
My stylist, who helped me find
a non-sweatsuit outfit.
-Yeah.
-Because I'm a mom,
like, splattered in --
-Baby -- yeah.
-Literally
anything you can throw.
-Baby detritus, yeah.
-Oh, big time, big time.
That's my look.
He was like, "Oh, you know
you have to actually,
like, get dressed up
and do this."
And so I was like,
"Oh, I'll shove it in my bag."
And he was like,
"No, no, no, no, no.
You're not going to
shove it in your bag.
You're going to hang it up
on the plane."
And I was like, "Of course.
Of course I'm gonna do that."
And I did, but then
I left it there.
[ Laughter ]
Waltzed right off,
left it on the plane.
And then like -- and also,
I was wearing sweat pants
on the plane.
-Yeah.
-Got to the lady
at the Jetblue desk.
I was -- I was crying.
-Yeah.
-I also took off my mask
so she could see my frown.
So she would know it was like,
a full thing.
And yeah, and they had
to find this for me.
And I just, I really --
I was on the verge of
sweatsuit, but in fact,
it's this.
-Seems like we maybe owe
a shout out
to the good people at Jetblue.
-I know, I know.
I just want to say thank you
to the lady at the Jetblue desk.
I was like, "I'm going
to give you a shout out.
I'm going on
a television show tonight.
It's Seth Meyers."
She said, "I love that show."
-Oh, wow.
-Okay?
She said, "I love that show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, this is --
I'm always happy to see you.
This is such a wonderful reason
to have you here.
"Marcel the Shell"
was a short film,
a stop-motion film
you made years ago.
You posted it online,
and it became -- in my mind,
it's one of the sort of earlier
YouTube sensations.
Is that accurate,
my memory of it?
-That is accurate.
Your memory is accurate.
Yeah, it is.
It's sort of a wonder,
because anyone who knows
me knows I hardly know
how to turn on my computer.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, but Dean Fleischer-Camp,
who I made the short film with,
posted it on the Internet
after showing it to, like,
12 people at a comedy show
in Brooklyn.
And he showed it,
and one of them was like,
"That's such a nice thing.
Could I show it --"
I think,
"Can I show it to my mom?"
Who, like, had
a broken leg or something.
And so he put it
on the internet,
and we just thought it would be
for this one person, basically,
who wanted to
send a happy,
little thing to their mom.
And instead it went much,
much wider than that.
-Yeah.
-You obviously --
The voice is one of the
more endearing qualities,
although there are many
endearing qualities
about Marcel.
Do you -- you now have
an 18-month-old, Ida.
Do you read to her
in Marcel's voice?
-Yeah, I speak to her.
I sing to her.
She loves --
-She does. That's very good.
-Getting read to in this voice.
Yeah.
-That's great. Do you want --
Could you read to us
from a kids' book
of what it sounds like?
-I mean, you wouldn't happen to
have a kids' book behind this?
-I do. I wrote one.
-Oh, my God!
-It's, like,
available in stores.
It's no big deal.
-Oh, wow.
-Here.
-So people could,
like, they could buy this?
-They could buy it, I guess.
It's, like, in stores.
It's super weird.
-Yeah, that's like, so weird.
-There you go.
You start from the beginning,
so you don't spoil the ending.
-Got it, got it. Got it.
"There once was a bear...
[ Laughter ]
...who was easily scared."
Oh, that's really sad.
-Yeah. It stays sad.
It never gets better.
[ Laughter ]
-"Each night
before going to sleep,
he would tie a bell
to his door that would
make a noise if anyone
tried to sneak in.
Because even a bear
who is easily scared
is a very heavy sleeper."
That's true. That's true.
-Bravo.
[ Applause ]
So I feel like --
-That's really cute.
-Thank you.
I feel like your daughter is
going to have
incredibly good hearing,
because Marcel does not project.
-He can't project at all.
That's why I have to ram my
finger into my own ear.
-Now, you are obviously
one of the voices in this.
And then you reached out and you
got, for Marcel's grandmother --
-Yeah.
-A real incredible pull.
-It's Isabella Rossellini.
-Which is amazing.
-Can you believe it?
-How did it happen?
-So we wanted
Marcel's grandmother,
whose name is Nana Connie,
which is also
the name of my grandmother,
whose name is Nana Connie.
We wanted her
to have a distinctive voice,
maybe an accent.
One of my grandmothers
has an accent.
And so we were like,
"Well, it's a long shot,
but maybe we'll just ask.
Whatever."
And they presented it to her
and she was like,
"I don't know what this is.
[ Laughter ]
Never heard of it."
And her children were like,
"No, we like Marcel the Shell.
You should do it.
You should do it."
And so she just said yes,
kind of like, just because
her kids said it was worth it.
But we didn't even have
a script.
The film is improvised off
of a treatment.
Like, a long document,
basically.
And so she showed up
and was like --
-And showed up
not at a studio.
-Right, right.
That's the other thing.
It's not like "Zootopia,"
where you show up
and they're like, "Hi, this Is
all the hors d'oeuvrs
in the world."
-Yeah.
-You know, like, "We're Disney.
Would you like, you know,
a pheasant..."
-Hummus.
-"A pheasant hummus?"
Which they're famous for at
Disney, is the pheasant hummus.
-You really got
to grind up the pheasant.
[ Laughter ]
-I just filled up
on that ground-up pheasant.
Anyway, she came to our rental,
where we were recording
with microphones taped
to the middle of our heads.
This is what you call
an indie film.
And we had nothing to offer.
Like, we had like,
some snacks and stuff,
but we were like,
"So, Isabella Rossellini,
what do you like on Postmates?"
Like it was --
-Did you ever order
Postmates for
Isabella Rossellini?
-Yeah, we got Thai food.
We got Thai food.
-I think, you know,
the Hollywood gossip mongers
want to know,
what does Isabella Rossellini
order from a Thai restaurant?
-You know,
I can't exactly remember,
but I'm thinking, like,
"I'll have the summer rolls."
[ Laughter ]
You know, like, beautiful,
beautiful, beautiful voice.
-You know, obviously,
this is a summer movie.
It makes sense.
It's a giant, big-budget, as we
established, summer movie.
-Yeah.
-And what would you say to
the people who are,
you know, maybe it's like,
are we going to go see
"Maverick"?
Are we going to go see
"Marcel the Shell
With Shoes on?"
Like, how do you help them
make that choice?
-Sure.
I mean, let me say on camera,
I don't want to insult
Tom Cruise in any way.
So I think you should
maybe see both films.
But I definitely think
you should see ours.
And -- the other thing is,
I heard a rumor, truly,
when I was on the
"Alvin and the Chipmunks" movie.
That's how all
Hollywood stuff starts.
"When I was there talking
to an invisible chipmunk."
No, truly what I remember
is someone, like, popping
their head out of a plant
and being like, "Tom Cruise is
watching 'Marcel the Shell.'"
They told me that he watched it.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-That just, like,
percolated through Hollywood
till it found you on set?
-Completely, yeah.
-Wow.
-Which is crazy, because,
like, on that movie,
like, I am a human,
but the chipmunks are there,
and, of course,
they're, like, invisible.
I hate to break it to you,
but, yeah.
So there was kind of like,
no one on set also.
-Yeah.
-Someone being like,
"ba, ba, ba."
But I always sort of
held it with me,
and now that the movie's
coming out,
I know Tom's probably doing
a lot of press for his film.
-Yeah, I think he's out there.
Yeah.
-Yeah, I'm just sort of like,
"Sir, I really enjoy your work.
If you do like Marcel,
maybe you could just
share a little bit of
your spotlight with us.
And please let me know
if you want tickets."
[ Laughter ]
-That's so nice.
-Yeah.
-That would be so nice.
-It would be so nice
if Tom Cruise came to see
the Marcel movie.
-You know, in the beginning
of "Maverick,"
there's a video of him
being like,
"Thanks so much for
coming out to the movie."
-Yeah.
I feel like if he comes,
you should record
yourself being like,
"Thank you, Tom Cruise,
for coming."
-For sure.
Like, I should probably just
record that super quick.
-Yeah, so let's go right there,
and we'll play this.
If he comes,
this will start the screening.
-If he comes.
Hi, Tom.
[ Laughter ]
It's Jenny Slate,
the voice, co-creator, writer,
and co-producer of the film
you're about to see.
I just want to thank you so much
for taking the time
out of your busy schedule
to see our small film.
Indie film really,
really appreciates
everyone that watches it.
And I love you and I've always
thought you were really cute.
My favorite movie of yours
is "The Client."
[ Laughter ]
No, "The Firm"!
Oh, no, Tom, "The Firm."
We can edit. We can edit.
-Is he even in "The Client"?
-No, it's Sarandon!
[ Laughter ]
Tom, I'm so sorry.
-Oh, my God, this went terribly.
Jenny Slate, everybody!
"Marcel the Shell with Shoes On"
is in select theaters
on June 24th
and nationwide on July 15th.